Prop. 8, Section 8,
are we ready?
[cheers and applause]
Let's roast!
[bell dinging]
- Guy...
[woman laughing]
You like a Jeff Ross
beanbag chair.
[laughter, cheers and applause]
[organ music playing]
♪ ♪
- Jamar, you're so hot,
but you're so ghetto
and uneducated,
I never know whether I should
fuck you or try to teach
you Shakespeare through hip-hop.
[laughter]
[gun clicks, gunshot]
- Guy, you too fat to be
trying to ride dick, my nigga.
[laughter]
This nigga's so gay
he only came out the closet
so his daddy would spank him.
[crowd exclaiming]
- [laughs]
[crowd yelling]
- [yelling]
[laughter]
- Jamar,
at least my father waited for me
to come out of the closet
to reject me.
[crowd exclaiming]
Jamar--Jamar grew up poor,
but his mom did the best
with what she had.
Unfortunately, what she had
was crack cocaine.
He is very, very lucky that you
cannot pay for an abortion
with an EBT card.
[crowd exclaims]
- Guy, you look like
a malignant whale tumor.
- That's topical.
- It's a sad shame.
You got all that blood
and can't donate none of it.
[laughter]
- Thank you, Wave.
- Jamar's never met his dad,
which makes a lot of sense.
Women rarely keep in touch
with the guy who paid them
two bologna sandwiches
to fuck behind a dumpster.
[crowd exclaiming]
[siren wailing]
- That's it.
That's gonna do it.
Guy Branum, Jamar Neighbors.
[cheers and applause]
[laughs]
- I'm all up for presentation,
and this--when they came out
with the fans, I'm like,
"How's he gonna top that?"
And then he brought
his neighborhood.
[laughter]
[applause]
[all exclaim]
- Thank you, Wave.
- You did great, Guy,
but I gotta give it to Jamar
and his neighborhood.
[cheers and applause]
- I thought when you first
came out, like, it was over.
I didn't realize you was
going up against Jamal.
I seen Jamal before.
He's very, very risky,
and, um...
[laughter]
I've seen him before.
I was actually scared, and then
the comebacks was amazing.
I gotta go with Guy.
[cheers and applause]
- Yeah.
- Uh-oh.
- [speaks indistinctly]
- That's the first time
a black guy's ever voted
for a gay person.
All right.
D'Elia.
- You both seemed
very confident.
I--I think personally
it's tough,
but I gotta go with Jamar.
I mean, that fucking
beanbag chair joke, man.
[cheers and applause]
- It all comes down to you,
Jeffrey.
Who do you like?
- As always, Guy, your jokes
are so, so well-written.
The Shakespeare through hip-hop
joke, so funny.
- That was a good one, yeah.
- You're really becoming
just a great comic
and a super funny guy.
However, I think we all know
tonight was Jamar's night.
You killed it, buddy.
[cheers and applause]
- Love ya.
[hip-hop music]
[laughter]
♪ ♪
- Damn.
[crowd cheering]
Hey!
- Nigga, my mama
watching this!
It was fucking fantastic.
I was afraid, I'm not gonna lie.
- Oh, a gay guy didn't win
when it was an all-straight-guy
judging panel.
Surprise, surprise.
- Yeah, I feel that.
- Nah, he had a stronger night.
Gimme a kiss.
- All right, man.
My mama watching this.
Mama, I swear to God.
[laughs]